let's try another
bot
how about myself where am i actually
there i am
okay let's see how that works
okay london it is
that looks like a positional concession
so c3 e6 okay uh
yeah should i go b3 and a4 and all that
or just
let's go bishop e2
and um
with 95.
yeah it's kind of fun to use the third
person and say let's see what he does
but this is me
ah like that okay
and what am i supposed to do here so one
thing is rook takes b2 bishop b2 knight
c4
bishop c3 rook d1 and a check but
do i have enough for an exchange i don't
know the other is just deploying knight
e4
and then maybe queen g4
already then i'm getting worried he will
castle
oh that's annoying
i hate it when i do this to myself is
that how it goes
okay let's do that and see
oh that's annoying i didn't even see
that was possible i thought he had to
move the knight
uh what am i gonna do now
knight f6 isn't gonna work
queen g4 king h8 knight g5 looks
looks like i'm desperate which i
probably am
okay let's do if i go knight d6
he does what b5
or does he just play knight d3
nope he takes
i could try to
[Music]
simplify into some end game
ed6 knight d3 this is so annoying
being outplayed by yourself that's
ridiculous
okay let's do that
then let's do that
and we should like take only five
[Music]
oh this is go queen takes p7
[Music]
just desperately trying to weasel a draw
out of this one
okay what can i do
oh is he going to cheap on me with
everything
can i grovel with queen a7 with the one
d1 in b2
i would doubt it so let's move
ah but then he just gets windy oh no
he's letting me have this pawn
maybe that gives me a glimmer of hope
or maybe it doesn't he's just gonna go
between
i don't think this is going to end well
uh what can i do rook fd1 would that get
me anywhere
okay let's try to go to b3
hopefully can i i wish i could go to c2
now but i have a feeling i can't
so let's go queen c2 but then he goes
queen c4
okay let's do that
then if i go here what does it do the
key one he's gonna go queen b2 over
okay let's see how this goes
he is gonna go queen b2
so what have i got here
i don't immediately see the reputation
of rook c2 but
well what can i do
okay that's all very well but
if i approach with my king
okay let me step back
not really sure what the hell i'm doing
can i okay let's go before
and am i going to be lost because he's
gonna come kings
so let me put the rook here
then if i come here what we're gonna do
can i go k3 does that help
f5 okay
[Music]
should i take the pawn and then
[Music]
it should be a draw or maybe i can go b5
and try to be pretty about it
either might be an f4 check ah let's
just take the pawn and hope for the best
i'm not sure what that pt move is for
but let me get in g3
and
let's go here
maybe i should have gone h4
okay let's go up the board and see if
that helps a little bit
oh i can get some checks in now
i don't even know where my piece is
anymore let me go
eight oh that was unfortunate because
i've allowed him to get his pawn to h3
and then my h2 pawn is going to be weak
and suddenly this position isn't looking
even remotely defensible anymore
okay still i would rather be active than
passive so let's go with that
okay
okay
[Music]
and let's try attacking his pawn for a
while
oh is he gonna go rook
this has got to be the silliest cheapo
of all time okay
[Music]
you know i can't tell if i'm a complete
nitwit or what the hell is going on
what am i supposed to do should be
it should be a fairly simple draw by now
i think
but i think i can still mess it up badly
okay for what it's worth let's go there
and hope for the best
and let's take that pawn
let's grovel back
and see oh h2 and g3 oh
damn
i'm not sure why he's doing this okay
yeah unfortunately f3 would be too
clever by half
and what can i do it's gonna go king g6
and rook at 7.
yeah you can trust your computer to find
a even simple win
i have no idea what is why is not
doing some sort of obvious thing but
maybe this is better technique
what should i do now
can i go f5
i have to do something
and then grovel back
drawable back
oh wow my bot is as
lousy in technique as i am
my bot did not impress in this one
so because i'm playing my bot uh i
should assume that
my technique will be as bad as his and
so maybe i shouldn't celebrate yet but
okay let's try the check
and let's try a check again
nice one century a nice one let's go
there
let's give a check over there
not sure what he hopes to accomplish
with this
when can i get f3 in can i get root j
and f3 or should i just go to the side
let's go to the side
i like the way he's just left a fixed
response do you believe in this check
so
oh it's so irritating when computers
force you to play all 80 moves so
whatever the hell they make you play
maybe i can actually play king h
two
am i blundering something again let's
uh no i can't be blundering anything now
let me get the eighth rank that's always
a nice one to have
because then i check him again yes i
believe in this check
yeah it feels like i should be able to
play f3 somewhere here but
let's go there oh
here f3
but he'll go to b2 check
let's try king g3 you can always
squiggle back
the next one okay so now i can play f3
and unless i'm
seriously mistaken this should be just
[Music]
yes
let's come back
and let's go there
okay
even his understanding is bad as bad as
mine he's continuing to play with rooks
this is a magnus thing
check
my deep study of pancura
i think i can now hold this position
finally
well i'm very impressed uh that my bots
technique is as bad as mine
that's a kind of touch of authenticity
right there